[Musik]
[Applaus]
robert du bist du wissen spezialisten
und stoffe darunter comspot band muss
nur kurz
was machen sie hier
wir haben die väter gab gemeldet sich
wie befolgen zur besichtigung der
general stücke nicht alle dürfen die
gerne als stimme vertreten hatte
das sind doppelt an der militär gemisch
an dass du hier bist agenten darf sind
die sowas zu haben die akademie wurde
1752 von marbella gegründet mit dem
auftrag magersüchtige offiziers und
recht ja viele männer sind natürlich
auch echte frauen junge menschen die das
gefühl haben das wäre vielleicht was für
mich welche voraussetzungen muss man
mitbringen
die matura und entsprechend mit
körperlicher und geistiger fitness
ausnahmeverfahren höchstalter zum
eintritt 37 ist das werk und es sind
also drei kategorien malerei nicht wohl
aber jetzt zumindest nehmen das mal
anfang ein bisschen mehr
jetzt kommt doch etwas neues dazu und
das ist gänzlich hier sollen neue schule
entstehen schule verführen und
einzigartige modell der handelsakademie
focus sicherheitsregeln für
persönlichkeitsentwicklung einer starken
währung september militär gelegt das ist
uns wichtig auf der einen seite den
medien aber auch akademisch
ausgelassenes als bachelor of arts
wir sind mit führungskräfte da ist im
hörsaal wenn es dann wird viel taktik
aber auch es gibt meistens gelände sah
da habe ich meine mutter hier habe ich
schon gesehen
dieser teil der ausbildung ist also nur
das auch die auslandserfahrung der
austausch in dem fall mit den jungen
mann aus frankreich sowohl das ist ein
ganz fitter wenn unsere werke liga gehen
die spd-linke in europa und umgekehrt
von mir aus deren akademische ausbildung
benutzen auch modernste ausbildungsweg
die hier die simulation und du solltest
jetzt mal in den hörsaal gehen und dort
mal einsteigen diesem recht gute
eigentlich schon gewonnen
ja herr ein gefeierter grad gemeldet
sich zum unterricht ist meine freude
lieber robert beer nimmt doch platz
[Musik]
ich sehe du hast keine unterlagen mit
daher unterstützen wir den robert
stellen meinen unterlagen umfallen das
taktische geschick zur verfügung um
nicht gänzlich unvorbereitet das
taktische gesteckt habe es ist alles da
mit diesem besteck willst du hier nicht
viel reißen sind wir dann taktisch mehr
vergessen
da geht es rechts schon frei
wenn wir in das gefecht zu bedenken dann
haben wir hier
der angreifer und auch einen verteidiger
wer der beiden wird eigentlich das
aktivere element sein wo wir bitte
einfach ich muss eine wegstrecke von
annas bezirklichen alles ist so einfach
- aber grundsätzlich richtig sie nach
rechts blicken sehen sie unsere fünf
bordwände ich bräuchte jetzt vier
freiwillige und durch die ich lieber
robert versuchen sie besonders aus dem
gesichtspunkt der synchronisation der
kräfte phasen zu finden in denen sie
[Applaus]
bitte führen sie ihren auftrag durch
[Musik]
ich glaube das würde mich freuen wenn du
nicht nur element in einer nacht man
hier nachzeichnet
[Musik]
bitte was soll das darstellt versuche
ich mir zu erklären
einen auftragsschub torjäger und diesen
berg hier eine beobachtung position und
anstieg geht zwar hubschrauber rein die
erledigen wirst du und wir kommen dann
nach
danke klingt interessant und einige
grundlagen kann ich erkennen das ist
sehr okay wie kann zum beispiel sehr
schön verzeichnen ist bei uns in der
taktik sehr wichtig wobei ich aber doch
noch einige defizite erkennen
schade daher würde ich vorschlagen dass
du die nächste pause und dunklen dazu
nutzen um noch ein wenig selbststudium
zu betreiben damit du dir in der
weiteren phase bei uns an der
militärakademie etwas leichter trust da
alles gleich fast schon ein problem als
und es war meine freude daraus ja bitte
darum
[Musik]
es sieht es wie folgt aus wir haben der
zug starke feld kräfte in steinbach
jetzt möchte ich wissen wie das gefecht
aussehen kann
meldeschluss kompanie frank frye
unterstützung durch nahezu ganze
kreative zu meinem buch und als er bei
der gepanzerte jäger zu genau das doch
für die erste phase wird das beziehen
der abläufe sind die zweite phase ist
das überdrehten ablauf linie dritte
phase ist das beziehen für die
ausgangsstellung der heuer unterstützung
und die letzte phase ist die phase wo
wir wirklich in die ortschaft einbrechen
werden
[Musik]
laage information fan teile vernichtet
der angriff ist damit beendet
der auftrag ist es die kommt man die
kraft an und nimmt steinbach im gesetz
gibt es jetzt irgendwelche fragen wer
ist ein einfacher beschicken 34
blackhawks und robert aufsetzen
[Musik]
abmarsch
wir passen wieder zurück
[Musik]
rothensteiner straße eingefahren
wir rufen die blackhawks jetzt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
sein lager aufklärung hat ergeben im
raum gehalt gruppe eindruck die panzer
erwarten mitwirkung entlang des weges
dieser weg ist für uns und für die
bevölkerung nicht darauf verwendbar
deshalb entschluss der reiff nahm um die
bewegungs linie für ein weiteres folgen
der komponist freizuhalten
für die hauptlast bei den zug
selbständige hofft luke an
war ein teil
unser auftrag ist es dass man den feind
im bereich unhcr anlage aufhören
gerade aus 100 und komik einschätzen
[Musik]
35 430 lagemeldung angriffsziel genommen
und wir rufen setzte sich fünf sind ein
freund es ist wahnsinn oder am anfang
alles in der theorie war sie die planung
auf der landkarte und dann fortbewegung
ziemlich viel wieder mal übrigens
gewonnen und jetzt gibt es ein café oder
wo gibt es im café
das ist eine einen überblick bekommen
was ist die militärakademie bedeutet der
offiziers büro von mittelmeer-insel
offiziere aus und ich darf dir gerne ein
patch militär kette mit anheften alles
gute danke fürs bessere lehre
ich möchte ich unbescheiden sein aber
normalerweise wenn man dann am schluss
die diakonie verlässt kriegt man doch
sowas werden sondern profitabel
habt ihr wirklich etwas mitgebracht
organisiere ich glaube dass angepasst
herren zu dem was das ist gelernt und
sind dadurch die gerne mitnehmen
ok kurz was der herr trägt das ist
natürlich auf die größe kommt halt nicht
immer artig danke dir ganz egal ob
österreichische bundesheer eine
schrauben nachgezogen wird oder sich
ganz nach plan zum verband könnte
übersetzt
ganz egal was immer geschieht es gibt
immer jemanden der entscheidet das ist
passiert wann es passiert und wo es
passiert und zwar quer durch alle ebenen
hier ist die schmiede dieser talente
hier findet eine ausbildung statt auf
basis von jahrhundertelanger tradition
aber heute mittwoch die ersten maßnahmen
modernster technik wäre ich ein bisschen
jünger wäre ich ein bisschen fitter
vielleicht will ich mir sowas dann in
groß holen wenn ihr so jemand sein
wollen dann benötigen jetzt schon oma
ist ja sehr aufregende karriere
genau hier beginnt
[Musik]